E
IN AMERICA PUSH IS A TOTAL
FARCE.
ALMOST LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE, A
COMPLETE LIE.
HERE IS THE FOUNDER OF THE
COMMITTEE TO UNLEASH PROSPERITY,
STEVE MOORE AND FORMER WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF REINCE
PRIEBUS.
STEVE, YOU AND YOUR GROUP DID AN
ANALYSIS ABOUT HOW IF WE STUCK
WITH THE TRUMP ENERGY POLICIES
IT WOULD BE $100 BILLION ADDED
TO OUR GDP?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SEAN.
WHEN I USE TO TALK TO DONALD
TRUMP ABOUT ENERGY POLICY BACK
IN 2016 WHEN HE WAS FIRST
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, HE ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE SELLING THE
STUFF AND NOT BUYING IT.
AT THAT TIME EVERYBODY IN THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS LAUGHED
SAYING THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
IT DID HAPPEN AND WHAT A
DIFFERENCE 20 MONTHS MAKES.
NOW BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S WAR ON
AMERICAN ENERGY, OIL, GAS AND
COAL WHICH WE HAVE MORE OF THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTRY, IT IS REALLY
PATHETIC THAT WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT HAS TO GO
PROSTRATE IN FRONT OF THE SAUDIS
AND ASKED THEM TO INCREASE OIL
PRODUCTION WHEN THEY DID JUST
THE OPPOSITE.
THE BOTTOM LINE FROM OUR STUDY,
WE COULD BE PRODUCING 3 MILLION
MORE BARRELS A DAY.
THAT WOULD BE $100 BILLION A
YEAR.
WE WOULDN'T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
THE SAUDI PLENARY S.
DO YOU REMEMBER US TALKING ABOUT
OPEC WHEN TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT?
NO.
BECAUSE HE MADE THEM A TOOTHLESS
TIGER.
NOW THEY HAVE TEETH AGAIN AND
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO INJURE THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
>> FOR THE LIFE OF ME, REINCE
PRIEBUS, WE WERE PAYING A LITTLE
OVER $2 A GALLON FOR GASOLINE.
WE ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
WE WERE A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY.
VLADIMIR PUTIN TURNS OFF THE
SPIGOT IN WESTERN EUROPE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SUFFER.
PEOPLE MAY LITERALLY FREEZE TO
DEATH THIS WINTER THERE.
WHY IS IT NEVER AN OPTION?
WHY IS IT A BETTER OPTION TO
SUCK UP TO MBS OR SUCK UP TO A
MURDERING THUG DICTATOR IN
VENEZUELA OR SUCK UP TO OPEC OR
SUCK UP TO THE IRANIAN MULLAHS
WHEN WE HAVE MORE NATURAL
RESOURCES HERE THAN MOST OF
THESE COUNTRIES COMBINED?
WHY WOULD HE NOT CHOOSE THE
POLICY WHERE WE CAN DO IT
CHEAPER, CLEANER AND FASTER?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> I DON'T GET IT EITHER.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE LIBERAL POLICIES OF THIS
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND THIS
INCREDIBLE FASCINATION WITH
SHUTTING DOWN GAS, OIL, FOSSIL
FUELS AND INSTANT MARRIAGE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL EXTREMISM IS WHAT
HAPPENS.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON DAY ONE.
ON DAY ONE ON EXECUTIVE ORDERS
HE SHUT DOWN THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
DEMOCRATS SAY IT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE HANDLED
SOMETHING EIGHT YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD.
PART OF SETTING THE PRICE ON GAS
AND OIL IS WHAT THE SUPPLY IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN EIGHT
YEARS.
HE SHUT DOWN THESE.
I WENT DOWN TO HOUSTON THIS
WEEKEND MET WITH A LOT OF BIG
ENERGY COMPANIES IN THAT SPACE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY?
IF YOU ARE IN OUR WORLD AND
ASKING US TO SPEND TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON ENERGY,
IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION THERE
IS NO WELCOMING MAT FOR US TO
INCREASE PRODUCTION.
ONLY TO SUFFER.
YOU TALK ABOUT BIDEN'S SPEECH
TODAY AND HE IS HAMMERING
REPUBLICANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS HAPPEN,
HE'S GONE BACK TO THE 1970S
PLAYBOOK.
HE HAS GONE BACK TO SAYING
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO GET RID
OF SOCIAL SECURITY.
THEY WILL GET RID OF MEDICARE.
LOOK AT WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS DONE.
LOOK AT WHAT HE HAS DONE IN TWO
YEARS.
HE HAS INFUSED THIS ECONOMY WITH
GOVERNMENT HANDOUTS AND HAS MADE
AMERICANS POORER.
IT'S LIKE WHAT RONALD REAGAN
SAID YEARS AGO.
YEARS AGO THE GOVERNMENT
DECLARED WAR ON POVERTY AND
POVERTY WON.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AMERICA.
>> STEVE MOORE, HOW LONG WOULD
IT TAKE AMERICAN ENERGY
COMPANIES TO GET UP AND RUNNING?
I WOULD ARGUE IF BIDEN GAVE THEM
A TEMPORARY REPRIEVE, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE VERY HESITANT TO
INVEST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO GET THESE THINGS OF
AND RUNNING BECAUSE THEY WILL
SAY WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO SHUT
IT DOWN AGAIN?
WHEN WILL YOU GIVE IN TO THE
RADICAL CLIMATE CULT IN YOUR OWN
PARTY?
IF WE REALLY WANTED TO RATCHET
UP PRODUCTION, HOW LONG WOULD IT
TAKE IN THIS COUNTRY?
I WILL ADD ONE OTHER THING.
IF THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE WAS
FINISHED WE WOULD BE GETTING
DAILY 900,000 BARRELS OF OIL
FROM CANADA EVERY DAY.
>> IT AIN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
UNDER THIS PRESIDENT.
EVEN HEAT THEY MADE A
DECLARATION TOMORROW THAT I
CHANGE MY MIND, I DON'T THINK
THE ENERGY COMPANIES WILL
BELIEVE HIM.
THE ONE PROMISE THAT JOE BIDEN
ACTUALLY KEPT.
DO YOU REMEMBER IN THAT FAMOUS
DEBATE WITH TRUMP THAT BIDEN
SAID I WANT TO CLOSE DOWN THE
OIL AND GAS COMPANIES.
HE HAS DONE THAT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT GAS PRICES NOW
GOING UP TO FOR $50.05 A GALLON
AGAIN.
I HAVE A FRIEND IN LOS ANGELES
THAT E-MAILED ME WITH A LITTLE
CHART THAT SHOWED THEY ARE NOW
PAYING $6.99 IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MIDDLE CLASS IS GETTING
CRUSHED AND THOSE PRICES WILL
CONTINUE TO GO UP.
>> CALIFORNIA AT $6.50 PER
GALLON.
IN NEVADA IT IS $5.50.
IN OREGON IT'S OVER $5.
IT'S ALL COMING BACK.
LAST WORD, REINCE PRIEBUS.
>>> JUST TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
SAID IN THE LAST SEGMENT.
YOU HAVE TO PUT REPUBLICANS IN
CHARGE OF THE CONGRESS.
AT THE VERY LEAST YOU WILL PUT A
CHECK ON BIDEN.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS LOVE TO
FACTION.
I THINK WASHINGTON, D.C. NOT
GETTING SOMETHING DONE FOR A
WHILE MIGHT BE JUST PERFECT FOR
OUR COUNTRY